il est bavard françois hollande et n'a
pas la langue dans sa poche un long
entretien au nouvel obs et 6 160 pages
de confession dans un livre un président
ne devrais pas dire ça car
malheureusement les journalistes qui ont
écrit ont raison un président de la
république ne devrait pas s'exprimer
comme ça ne devrait pas faire ces
confidences partir le port du voile
la femme voilée d'aujourd'hui sera la
marianne de demain avec ces mots le
locataire de l'elysée estime que le
voile peut être une protection pour une
citoyenne mais que demain elles sont
libérera prg il ya un problème avec
l'islam
et d'ajouter que ce n'est pas la
religion qui est dangereuse en elle-même
mais que le problème c'est que l'islam
veut s'affirmer comme une religion dans
la république car je suis très surpris
de voir françois hollande le dire parce
qu'il a longtemps nié
après avoir lancé une campagne
d'affichage anti migrants avec le slogan
ça y est ils arrivent
robert ménard a annoncé la tenue d'un
référendum en janvier prochain en cause
l'agrandissement d'un des deux centres
pour réfugiés de la ville
le président n'en reste pas là y compris
sur les ténors de son compte
jean marc ayrault quand il était premier
ministre tellement loyal qu'il est
inaudible
nadjaf vallaud belkacem elle est bonne
najat très forte en langue de bois
les verts des cyniques et des emmerdeurs
nicolas sarkozy qualifié de grossier et
méchant en prend aussi pour son grade
c'est le petit de gaulle c'est un lapin
duracell toujours en train de s'agiter
cas mais je prends pour victor hugo
il a des confidences qui sont très
sérieux mais très franchement
impressionnant la république n'a pas à
faire ces confidences un an lui demande
pas ça on s'en foutent et confident il
ya une chose qui m'étonne c'est qu'il
ait le temps de passer des centaines
d'heures avec des équipes de
journalistes diverses et variées c'est
le deuxième livre de ce genre là il ya
un mois il y en avait un autre aussi
avec deux journalistes qui révèle l
avoir vu plusieurs dizaines de fois qui
passe son temps à voir des journalistes
mais c'est que ce qu'ils n'avaient pas
d'autres choses à faire et ce qu'ils
n'avaient pas s'occuper des affaires de
la france pour gaver du temps consacré
il a pris du temps dans leur idée mais
je pense qu'il a estimé que le livre
qu'on faisait serait et à juste titre un
livre de fonds l'ex compagne de françois
hollande et qui publie donc via twitter
un sms qu'elle attribue à françois
hollande datait de 2005
ouais d'accord avec ça je laisse les
français faire leur jugement dans son
discours à la fin la plus formidable
réserve générale même chez les sens dans
il faut supprimer le ps toute façon le
ps ne sert plus à rien aujourd'hui c'est
ce qui nous dit en substance et nous dit
je pense qu'il faut créer un nouveau
parti qui s'appellerait pourquoi pas le
parti du progrès et que ce soit valls et
cambadélis qui pousse cette idée là il
n'a pas loin de parler d'immigration
on n'a pas parlé des impôts on n'a pas
le droit de parler d'identité de la
france ô à moins qu'elle soit heureuse
soyons ravi il y en a toujours un an la
crèche